Dan Shaughnessy Boston Globe columnist
who joins us now Dan summarize your
column if you can for our viewers and
listeners well Dan so the point of
contention we believe between Belichick
and Brady is is the trainer Alex
Guerrero who was around in a big way for
years on the sideline team claim team
hotel opposite at Gillette and bill
basically banished him from the premises
last year where he can treat Tom and Tom
only on the premises and no longer
travels with the team he's on his own
basically and Tom still believes in him
the guy's been great for Tom and but a
lot of other players are gravitating
toward the Ellis garel method and and
the Guerrero has a very shady track
record you know all kinds of being
sanctioned by the feds and lying about
being a doctor and his degrees and
whatnot so you've got that situation
which is create attention with with
Brady and Belichick the reason probably
why Brady's not at the OTAs for the
first time this week and not with this
teammates and and so you have that and
there's been some push well why doesn't
bill just yield and let Guerrero be
around and then on the next day Julian
Edelman Brady's favorite guy favorite
receiver he gets popped for four games
allegedly it's being contested and he's
another client of Guerrero now that
doesn't mean that there's anything
Guerrero did to supply we don't know
that but it's just a bad optic that as
this thing is coming to a head that a
Guerrero guy gets popped for peds
there's a part of your column that says
the following let's revisit for a moment
exactly who Guerrero is he's a guy who
said he was a doctor even though he was
not a doctor he marketed a beverage of
organic greens that falsely claimed
could prevent or cure cancer heart
disease arthritis and diabetes and lied
about receiving a bachelor's degree in
biology has Tom Brady been asked about
all of these things like why does he
believe in him if these things are made
up I think Tom has written it off as
youthful indiscretions on the part of
Alex Guerrero
tom is very tied into this individual
Tom's son is the godson of Alice
Guerrero that if you look at all the
Instagram pictures from last week when
Tom was in in Monaco at the Grand Prix
and throwing passes off the yachts you
know Guerrero's there they're very much
tied at the hip and it's worked for Tom
you know I mean so in his mind this is
the way to go
you can play till you're a hundred and
you can make yourself impervious from
all injury and concussion and everything
else you can become Wolpe capable and
increasingly like Gronkowski's over
there and and the element was over there
so but also a guys like Hightower and
Edelman are Guerrero guys they were both
out for the year last year with injuries
you also point out that you know given
his snake-oil background why should we
believe in that he had nothing to do
with you know this Julian Edelman
situation here
well someone who's had the the track
record of Alex Guerrero certainly is
it's not unreasonable to questioned when
when this thing comes up I mean it's
like if you're going to sell concussion
juice and you know supreme greens to
cure cancer and [ __ ] shut down by the
feds twice what would prevent you from
doing this and this is not that we don't
know but it's just again it just it
fortifies Bellatrix case for not having
him around
as far as Edelman sitting out for four
games coming back from an injury not the
first guy who if this is the case that
you're coming back from an injury and
you use peds to come back but in his age
it's kind of a tricky age I would think
or is you know is he different than Wes
Welker at 32 well I think what you say
is true Dan I mean if you go back I mean
Nick a [ __ ] got popped and he was never
the same again in that age area Rodney
Harrison who gave him a couple great
years here was never the same you know
being caught at that age go back to
Shawn Merriman who was younger but you
know he was he was a great great player
and it was never the same so I don't
know whether it's like you can't be as
loose with the pharmaceuticals once
you've been caught or that you're in
your early 30s and you're just trying to
hang on and stay as great as you were
and getting some help
I mean you and I are adults we probably
think everybody in the NFL has gone
something how else could you play the
game is so barbaric it's like it's not a
surprise in the league the league
doesn't really I don't want to say
doesn't care about it but they don't
police this you know vigilantly and I
think there's a lot of looking the other
way because it's just kind of assumed
that everybody needs a little something
well you know as soon as we heard the
news about Edelman we came in this
morning and we all were looking back on
an interview that he did when he was
putting out that book the children's
book and he came in the studio and he
talked about work ethic and his dad and
making him proud and I don't know maybe
I'm being naive here but but it felt
like boy this would if it if something
like that happened it would really crush
his dad that does it fit in with the
character here you even looked at that
with Edelman that is he that kind of guy
who needs to get that edge or he
wouldn't be in this position without
something like this everybody loves the
guy you know his little guy is drafted
as a quarterback I mean Belichick kind
of made him you know by taking a
quarterback and you know changing his
position and and really making him a
great weapon here and he's worked great
with Brady and he was way down the depth
chart the early years so you know with
people like Walker leaving and he was
able to elevate and that catch he made
against the Falcons really won the Super
Bowl anyway you want to look at it I
mean it did and so he's a much beloved
local guy and and no one no one takes
any any joy in seeing this sort of thing
come out but in that sport again Rodney
Harrison perfect example his reputation
is almost flawless nobody cares that
that happened years ago I mean he's just
stand-up guy and a man's man and is not
punished for it and I don't think
Edelman will be either as far as depth
goes at wide receiver they brought in
another you know cast of characters here
so how would you handicap what they have
because you know you lose cooks and
you're using Danny Amendola now you got
Edelman down for four games right that's
it's you know it might it might not be
the worst thing given that you know he's
gonna get not gonna have to rush back
and have four more games and we're
coming off this injury the pacing is
probably not the worst thing for him as
for Brady yeah it's running out of
targets with with Amendola gone him
still
for games you know we know grants going
to be there they've got they've got some
young people there and Tom wasn't that
the OTAs with them unfortunately but but
Dan you and I both know that when we're
talking in January they will be on their
way to the AFC championship I mean I
mean it's not like the Dolphins the Jets
or the bills are going to challenge them
they're going to get where they want to
go it's just a matter of can they
execute in the big games at the end I
one final question it has nothing to do
with peds Edelman or any of that stuff
but it has to do with Boston sports I
got into this discussion with my guys
earlier in the week because Mookie Betts
is a guy that I would pay to see I think
it he's he's sort of the East Coast
version of Mike Trout if I said you
could have Bryce Harper or Mookie Betts
to start your team oh boy that's a tough
one you know you really got me on the
spot there I it sounds a little crazy
but I might go with that's just because
I we just don't know where the ceiling
is with this guy and he was an infielder
just four years ago and has had a good
track record with injuries so I'm just
that that's a you can't go wrong either
way crazy but I'll say that's yeah I
just
maybe I'm waiting for more from Harper I
think I think Betts is more consistent
yeah sort of like Trout is you know you
get to the point where you sort of
expect Mookie Betts to be great every
day it feels like Harper has those
moments where he has a greater moment he
just doesn't he's not as consistently
great as the other two in my opinion so
I mean you can't go wrong but I I would
go with Betts even though if I'm selling
the flamboyancy in a face of a franchise
right then it might be Bryce Harper but
Mookie Betts he's in the conversation
let's put it that way the old questions
it's all it's all ahead for him and the
ceilings unlimited great stuff Dan have
a good weekend thanks for joining us
thanks Dan take care
Dan Shaughnessy Boston Globe stirring it
up a little bit for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you
[Music]